you've probably heard of four states of
matter solid liquid gas and plasma but
there's a fifth ultra cold state that is
attracting a lot of attention the
bose-einstein condensate discovered
during the late 20th century and the
object of intense research ever since
this year a condensate will make its way
to the space station but why is this
material suddenly rocketed to prominence
and just what is a bose-einstein
condensate B EC gets its name from the
two scientists who proposed its
existence Satyendra Nath Bose and Albert
Einstein they suggested that when
certain atoms are cooled to temperatures
near absolute zero the atoms lose their
individual identities and crowded into a
single quantum state seventy years after
the proposal scientists finally achieved
the temperatures needed to generate the
condensate to get these atoms super cold
scientists used lasers lasers can be
tuned so that atoms preferentially
absorbed photons when they move towards
the laser absorbing these laser photons
slow down and cool the atoms inside a
vacuum chamber an array of laser beams
cool a few atoms trapped within a
magnetic field to just fractions of
degree above absolute zero
just like Einstein predicted when the
temperatures get this low regular
physics seems to break down this new
matter forms into something called a
superfluid super fluids are fluids that
have zero viscosity meaning they flow
without any friction or resistance not
only that but ABEC can behave much like
light wave ABEC can overlap and
interfere with itself to spontaneously
develop a rippled wavy distribution of
atoms such wavelength effects are rarer
long forms of matter so physicists are
excited to study their intricacies but
they only have milliseconds in which to
study the BCS after they release the
atoms from their magnetic traps and
gravity brings them crashing to the
bottom of their vacuum chamber
now scientists want to send B e sees the
space where weightlessness gives them
more time to perform experiments on
earth the best way to mimic the
weightlessness of space is by performing
experiments during freefall in bremen
germany scientists are dropping b ec
experiments down a 146 meters hour but
they need to get the cold items into
space if they want to probe their b ec
regularly for more than a few seconds
the cold atom laboratory is a
remote-controlled device that will
become operational in 2018 after it is
installed in the international space
station's Destiny module if all goes
well the C al will be churning out data
for at least a year after it is switched
on being in space also means they can
cool atoms to lower temperatures
scientists may reach record temperatures
below 100 Pico kelvins colder than any
spot in the universe weightlessness also
allows experiments to happen that
wouldn't be possible otherwise some
researchers are aiming to create B EC
bubbles a form of the condensate that
wouldn't be possible back on earth due
to gravity other scientists are looking
at the cooling not just atoms but
individual molecules well the space
station is a better environment than
Earth for maintaining becs vibrations
from the machinery onboard keep it from
being the perfect test bench in the
future space space experiments may be
able to perform atom interferometry on
the becs eventually these atomic
interferometers could be launched on
purpose-built satellites and used to
measure tiny variations in Earth's
gravity but for right now there's still
a lot we need to learn about the spiff
state of matter
you